2d plans are great but how can you
actually visualize the building that
you've been designing today i'm going to
show you exactly how to design
elevations in arcade 25. if you have no
idea what an elevation is today i'm
going to show you and explain to you
exactly what and how to make an
elevation in archicad 25. elevations are
basically the depiction of the floor
plan from a front on or side on view so
basically you're looking at this floor
plan that you see here on the screen
around all four perimeters i've gone
ahead and created this very very basic
box building to be able to demonstrate
the general fundamental basics of
elevations so if we start off with our
four elevation markers on the side
you'll see that we can use the ones
available on the arcad 25 template or we
can find the elevation markers here on
the left hand panel side it's
basically the one little black triangle
with the line underneath it if you're
looking for in the document palette
let's start by simply dragging all of
these elevations across to exactly where
they need to be now for the purposes of
this i'm going to drag them anywhere on
this document but you should be aware
that elevations are typically seen from
the boundary itself unless there is
something else that dictates where the
elevation must be seen from so if we
take these four elevation markers space
them around the building itself you'll
see the extent of the elevation is
showcased by these two black hot spots
at the end of each marker so if i click
on one of these hotspots go to my
stretch tool i can drag it down to as
low or as far away as i need from this
building in this instance it doesn't
really matter but if you want to
showcase more or less the building you
absolutely can now these four elevation
markers if we zoom in we'll see e03 e02
e01 and e04 respectively if you look at
them a little bit closer e03 indicates
on the right hand panel what that
elevation is actually called and a 301
indicates what page up the top in our
layout book we have actually placed that
elevation on so basically you know if
you look at that elevation on a printout
you'll find it on page 301 despite what
page you found the original marker on
now let's start by clicking on e01 and
experiencing what this looks like
generically straight out of the arcade
box as you can see we have our markers
on the right and left hand side that
indicate the levels if we press command
or control 7 we can change our story
settings here if we don't want to see
these blue markers on the right hand
side we just simply untick press ok and
they will disappear however for the
purposes of this we'll keep them on just
so we can showcase what they look like
again if i press command 7 and let's say
i change this ground floor plan to 27
press ok you'll see that automatically
adjust and automatically update to 7.
you can see that we've cut through the
ground itself we've showcased three
windows on the side and we've showcased
our very very basic building now
depending on what stage you're
showcasing and documenting an elevation
on the scope can be vast and wide it
could be as simple as what you see on
this picture right here today or it
could be extremely detailed outlining
individual elements so for example we
could use a text tool here change our
settings two and black and type in
vertical monument cladding
steel
by builder if we aren't actually
documenting the specific cladding and
then draw our line tool underneath
pointing to that cladding
and changing an arrow so we'd repeat
that same step for the window frames the
doors and everything between the roof
the barge the gutter everything we need
to showcase and detail there are a
number of different ways you can utilize
this you can use keynotes which is a ci
tools plugin you can use basic text you
can do a whole bunch of different
varieties basic text which means you
manually have to go back and override
every single time is probably the most
common and the most basic in arcade 25
after that you move to a bit more
advanced options and tools if we came
back to our ground floor plan now found
our elevation marker one and pressed
command t
we can see that our cut elements are cut
filled and non-shaded we can also see
that our uncut elements are the surface
colour fill if we didn't want that
elevation to be in full colour full 3d
we could simply go uniform pen colour
fill non-shaded press ok
and then double click on our elevation
again you'll see that automatically
update to a black and white line weight
option now i have made every single one
of these line weights exactly the same
so if we went up to view on screen
options and down to true line weight we
would see the exact line weight that it
would be printed now if i was to open up
this window setting go command t
and overwrite my line weight here from
0.3 to
0.25 not only would you see it as a
different color you would also see it as
a much thicker red line
so once you're in elevations it's very
important that we get our line weights
correct and we get all of our
information that we want to portray
across correct so if i undo that step
that window doesn't need to be read in
any way shape or form it would be a
different line way it would be something
else but for this instance we're just
showing you how to set up elevations
correctly now in an elevation you do not
want to see the cut through of the site
in full texture hatch now there are a
number of ways we can alter this we can
do that in 2d we can change our material
settings but for the purpose of this we
are literally going to go at our line
tool let's change that to a nice green
so we know where our line is change that
all the way up the top go to our fill
tool let's go 100
background and we'll make that white and
we'll simply just cover that entire
space there so if i change that get rid
of the line and make sure our green line
is to the front
we will now see that is our natural
ground level so if i replicate my text
we can go n g l standing for natural
ground level and fgl for future ground
level in most instances we now know that
our house sits approximately 86
millimeters below
the natural ground level which we would
indicate with some sort of dimension
markers we could use our dimension text
there outlining all three elements
clicking ok 86 three meters and we could
simply change that
to all black or whatever color we wanted
so that we knew exactly where our
natural ground level was and where our
building started now if we were to go
back to our ground floor plan we could
then again go command t for the purposes
of this on our elevation marker change
our uncut elements back to a texture
fill non-shaded go okay double click and
once again you'll see a very different
example of what that elevation could
look like now what you'll also see is
the shadows in this elevation that are
quite harsh and quite strong so if we
went back to elevation marker command t
we can scroll down to our sun
positioning here now our sun can be
custom at 45 degrees 45 degrees which
allows every single elevation to
replicate the exact same sun position
and keep it relatively clean and visible
some people might actually prefer to
have it as in 3d window so if we click
as in 3d window click ok and then if we
come up to view 3d view options and 3d
projection settings
then we can actually change our date and
time this is actually quite critical
because most of the time you're going to
be looking at the sun path in the winter
solstice here in australia that's on the
21st of the 6th and we'll do it as 2022
in this instance go back to our number
one elevation we'll see that those sun
paths rapidly change and those shadows
are completely different now you'll also
notice the shadows in this building are
for some reason white so if we go back
to our settings command t scroll down to
the bottom you'll see our shadows they
are 50
opacity let's change that 25 let's
change that to black go okay
let's go back to elevation one and now
you'll see those shadows a little bit
more pleasing and a little bit more
architectural we would have another
building behind it just to the right
backhand side now coming into elevation
marker three you'll see that building
appear in the back right hand side
very hard to differentiate what's
further what's closer if we were to
click on elevation mark three go command
t
and scroll down to our
fade distance elements we can quickly
press ok
change our distance marker to include
just this building and everything passed
to be in a different shade so clicking
on elevation 3 again we will see that
our main building is in focus and our
further building has been shaded out in
a light gray defined by the actual
settings anyway that's all for me today
guys thank you so much for watching i
hope you enjoyed the video if you did
like buttons down there subscribe
buttons down there and like always i'll
see you next monday